[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new stranger things
season 4 trailer video whole bunch of
familiar faces you may have recognized a
couple other people obviously everyone's
just talking about hopper so we'll break
it all down there a couple Easter eggs
here and we've added a little bit more
about what's going on with the season 4
episodes if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Easter
egg videos so we'll just do top 10 WTF
and Easter eggs as we go along so
starting with number 10 stranger things
drop this new season 4 trailer for
Valentine's Day
happy Valentine's Day everyone new
footage and they also posted some movies
that inspired some of the storylines
primarily prison themed as you can see
from this list but also John Carpenter's
the thing which i think is a reference
to the demagogue and
the white demagogue and that we saw in
the season 3 post credit scene if you
couldn't tell from the Russian him that
was being sung in the background with
all these Russian military guards and
then Hopper showing up this is obviously
meant to become chaka Russia in Siberia
so number 9 WTF hopper is revealed to be
alive and it answers a lot of questions
about the stranger things season 3 post
credits scene from Kamchatka we saw that
big long scene of the Russian military
prison where we saw the prisoner get
dragged out kicking and screaming down
to the pit where they fed it to the new
white demagogue on but they passed by a
cell and pause for a hot minute saying
no not the American myself a lot of
other people just assumed that they were
talking about hopper because he was the
major hanging plot thread at the end of
the season big mystery question what
happened to him we never saw a body in
by the rules and laws of television and
movies if you don't see a body that
means that they're probably coming back
the new teaser footage just confirms
that it was him inside that prison cell
but number 8 it doesn't confirm how he
wound up in that prison in Siberia I
think there are only two ways that it's
either a missing time period between the
blast and when the authorities made it
down there to inspect the facility there
were probably some other Russians that
weren't blown up in the blast that were
able to escape and they took hopper with
them the second option is that he
traveled through the upside-down gate
before it was closed but I think it's
the more practical explanation they were
probably just some Russians that weren't
killed there was a bit of a time gap
that allowed them to escape they took
hopper with them because he was present
for all this he was responsible for it
so they wanted retribution but they also
wanted to keep him from telling all
their secrets to the authorities
number seven WTF this is kind of fun you
may have noticed a very special new
guest star in the season four teaser
footage as they're panning before they
reveal hopper it's Jack and Hegar from
Game of Thrones
he just got done playing a villain on
Jack Ryan season 2 so he's done a lot of
stuff since he left Game of Thrones
typically he plays major badass
characters this footage implies he's
gonna be one of the Russian military
bosses in charge of whatever this new
project is going on during season four
he and hopper will probably wind up
having some kind of crazy Royal Rumble
rage in a cage every fight metaphor you
can think of r.i.p Alexei may he rest in
peace funny story - David Harbor is
obviously in the Marvel Black Widow
movie which is coming out in a couple
months he's playing a character called
Alexei szostak off aka red Guardian a
Russian just a really funny coincidence
that he is playing a character who's a
Russian and named Alexi after being in
stranger things season 3 with this
version of Alexi number 6 why is the
military forcing them to do this chain
gang constructing a railway through the
Siberian wilderness it's probably
something to do with whatever their
experiments in the Russian upside down
portals typically the only reason to
construct train tracks like this on a
military installation is for freight
trains that carry really large gear and
equipment so it probably something to do
with the Russians trying to open a new
portal to the upside down part of the
idea the upside down gates is that there
are strategic positions all around the
world where the barrier between
dimensions is weaker weak enough that
you can actually open a gate so you
can't just do it anywhere like 11 for
instance way back in the events before
season 1 she was super powerful she
opened the tear on accident but she was
only able to do it here because the
barrier between dimensions in the upside
down was weakened up if they would have
been somewhere else in the United States
it might not have worked
number 5 WTF that's part of the reason
why the first Russian gate wasn't
successful in the events in the
beginning of season 3 they then had to
come make the star court mall just to
serve as a mask for the fact they were
coming to the u.s. to hijack the Hawkens
portal and using the base underneath the
star court mall like they had almost
everything they needed at this Russian
location initially the barrier was weak
they just did not have an esper that was
as powerful as 11 but the Russians do
have their own Esper program just like
the 111 and her friends were part
speaking of which number four there are
nine episodes total during season four
typically there's only eight so that
extra episode kind of reminds you of
season two when we saw the other Esper's
from Elevens program number eight was
their leader in the last we saw them at
the end of stranger things season two
episode was riding off into the night
wondering if they'd ever pay that off
the whole reason for that episode in my
mind was just 411 to find other people
like her who had been through the same
thing it had the same type of powers
they didn't come back at all during
season 3 so it makes sense that they'd
come back during season 4 at some point
to pay off that storyline and maybe also
help 11 in the group stop the Russians
or defeat the mind flayer once and for
all obviously next big question number
three what happened to the mind flayer
the last we saw of the mind flayer it's
avatar was defeated in the season 3
finale the big creature in the star
court Maul wasn't the mind flayer itself
it was more of a transdimensional finger
puppet rat suit that the mind flare was
controlling from the upside down it
didn't physically enter earth the way it
seems like it was trying to remember way
back during season 2 was trying to lay
all that organic pipework underneath
hawkins infecting our reality so that it
could eventually just sort of walk into
our dimension at the end of season 3
they defeated the avatar and closed the
Hawkins gate again but the mind flayer
is still alive and well inside its home
dimension of the upside down remember
the other season 4 teaser trailer they
released last year it was all about them
going to the upside down of this footage
is basically the upside down version of
Hawkins in the text reads were not at
Hawkins anymore implying that they'll
travel physically into the upside-down
they left Hawkins at the end of season 3
not really sure when we'd come back or
if we'd come back at any point the
chimes of the clock ringing sound in
that teaser also scented like Big Ben's
chimes in London which may just be an
indication that they're taking a major
road trip to Europe and obviously Russia
to maybe try and rescue hopper like I
said the stranger things writers were
posting this list of movies that
inspired some of the episodes a lot of
them are movies set in prison but most
of them are about famous prison breaks
but here's the thing there's been talk
at Netflix of them doing stranger things
season 5 doing another season so I'm not
expecting them to actually go in to the
upside down and fully kill the mind
flayer in its own dimension until
the final season whatever that winds up
being the only other option for a final
season boss villain if you killed the
mine player during season four would be
for the mine player to possess one of
the characters so that one of the
characters that we know winds up being
the villain for the final season and I'm
not expecting them to take it that far
so early prediction the cliffhanger for
the season 4 finale will end with them
getting ready to fight the mind flayer
one-on-one inside the upside down like
they travel through dimensions but they
have to actually have the final battle
with the mind flayer 11 still doesn't
have her powers back that's probably
just part of a personal loss arc that
she'll be on during season 4 like she's
violent ever garden if you're a big
anime fan also a Netflix series she has
to learn to deal with the loss of her
surrogate father on that series 11 has
to learn to do the same thing because
hopper is her surrogate father spoiler
warning for violet ever garden but I
think we're all expecting that 11 will
get her powers back or she'll find a way
to access them again if she ever really
did lose them in the first place it
could just be something weird going on
in her head space they haven't
officially announced the release date
yet but a lot of people seem to think
that it's going to be Christmas this
year just based on the production
timeline and how long it takes them to
get episodes out in the fact that the
Netflix account was posting this right
at the end of December but everyone post
your theories in the comments below what
do you think is going to be happening
during stranger things season four I'll
do more bonus videos for the series as
they release more trailers and footage
there'll be another really big stranger
thing season 4 trailer in a couple
months while you wait for everything
everyone click here for that brand new
Robert Pattinson Batman teaser trailer
and click here for my new Avengers
infinity Saga deleted scene thank you so
much for watching everyone stay awesome
this is the way
[Music]